hey guys my name is Jess it is Tuesday
the 21st so much and we're here to talk
about video game news if you want some
of that every single day be sure to hit
that subscribe button but for now here's
what's going on yes the wait for red
dead redemption to is getting you down
I've got some good news a group of
modest unloading the first games map
into GTA 5 a group of fans led by
developer mr. leisurewear yes you heard
that right released these screenshots on
the GTA forums according to a post by
mod team member Jeff tick the
screenshots are two years of work by
miss Felicia where the team is currently
developing the map textures and the
game's day/night cycle there are plans
to mod more elements from the original
xbox 360 version of red dead redemption
if they can expand the team in a post
jessic wrote we are mostly looking for
programmers who are able to help us
reverse-engineer the file formats we're
also looking for scripters who are able
to remake any of the games original
content over to GTA 5 think minigames
and certain mechanics such as dead i
targeting obey the release of the map
which is only intended for single-player
use airs planned for this summer let's
face it average fans generally have
something to be excited about but today
is extra special as ariza has arrived on
public servers unfortunately your new
favorite tank won't be available for
competitive play just yet as lizard want
to give you time to learn to play her
first areas weapon is the fusion driver
an automatic cannon that deals constant
damage but slows your movement speed he
alternate fire deploys a charge she can
detonate to slow enemies and draw them
into the explosion her abilities include
the damage reducing fortify and
protective barrier a stationary shield
that can be deployed to block enemy
attack / ultimate is super charger which
launches a device the buffs damage done
by any teammates in its line of sight
Ariza has been available on over watches
tests over four weeks now and she's
already been tweaked once in other over
watching news the new patch which is out
on all platforms has made changes to
Bastion ammo
and other heroes so head to our story on
site to find out what's going on with
your main finally horizon zero dawn has
been updated Guerrilla Games have
detailed the one point 10 update on
reddit which adds among other things the
ability to hold X to purchase multiple
items from merchants as someone who
spent much of her 60 hours in the game
buying single units of wire and have
spent countless more hours bitching
about this very problem this is a
welcome addition the patch also enables
you to invert the x axis and makes
adjustments to item drop rate as well as
AI and progression fixes I won't details
them all now as some contains story
spoilers but if you're interested you
can check out the full list of changes
in our surrounding spot that is
everything I've got for you today do let
me know what you cared about in that
comment section head to gamespot we've
got stories on PlayStation Plus and
destiny and I will see you again
tomorrow